mais nabila voilà qui fait parler d'elle
parce qu'évidemment le 16 octobre
dernier elle a été donc condamné à
exécuter sa peine et sa peine elle avait
six mois de prison pour que vous
compreniez bien à cause de la terre du
couteau avec thomas et du coup la peine
a été transformée ce qu'on appelle les
travaux d'un terreau d'intérêt pradon
général et donc voilà elle doit les
faire et leur programme du jour c'était
entretien du biotech domaine des petites
étiquettes lavage des sols lavage des
toilettes et comme ces nabila et ben
même quand il s'agit on va dire de faire
des travaux d'intérêt général c'est
comme ça qu'il faut dire est pas
généraux eh ben elle ce film elle
commande tout ça a beaucoup choqué
certains qui disent qu'elles piétinent
un petit peu la justice d'autres ont
trouvé ça amusant
d'autant qu'à la fin de la vidéo vous
allez voir son copain thomas bien la
chercher en ferrari alors qu'elle vient
de de ba2 de vala de faire cesser ses
activités
est ce que ça vous choque ou pas
regardez je suis à la bibliothèque
voilà j'en ai travail aujourd'hui
ah bah forcément fallait qu'elle la
fasse est là on dit des travaux
d'intérêt général des travaux pour
l'intérêt général quoi bon mais parce si
elle fait du ménage et du rangement dans
une école de banlieue parisienne pendant
plusieurs semaines c'est à cause de
l'agression au couteau commise en 2014
sur son compagnon thomas
mais ce qui est vraiment génial chez
cette fille c'est qu'elle arrive à
transformer sa punition en une sorte de
télé réalité et comme à son habitude
elle nous parle sans filtre alors qu'est
ce que tu vas faire cet après midi une
habile homme du coup donc l'ont trahi
numéro un c'est compter tous les livres
de la bibliothèque et de mettre une
étiquette sur chaque les très vieux
ça a l'air bien compliqué ça et pour la
première fois de sa vie
madame reçoit des ordres et dont les
exécuter nom pouvait changer la poubelle
s'il vous plaît oui tout de suite
la wiiu fait voler ses compères juste un
détail et des toilettes schl ainsi aux
ballerines abila c'est vrai que c'est
pas marrant monsieur mieux que de faire
de la bride ont quand même et puis
heureusement ton copain thomas est venu
le chercher en friperie ça vous fait
avoir les pieds sur terre et sait
quelque chose de positif
ça c'est bien de réfléchir et ce qui est
bien c'est que ça continue encore demain
et sinon filmer les coulisses de sa
condamnation ça vous choque voilà est-ce
que ça vous choque ou pas je pose la
question je peux on va d'abord
évidemment posé la question à magali
berda qui la connaît très bien ça vous
étiez encore mais mon vrai dire la
vérité hier soir avec elle à 2 heures du
matin qu'à 2 heures du matin pour
rigoler watts et une heure moi j'ai fait
la connaissance de nabila cas on est là
c'est une fille très touchante je pense
qu'elle est allé vraiment catalogue mais
en soi c'est sa vie une habile elle est
comme ça moi j'ai discuté de ça avec
elle hier soir elle fait la bibliothèque
et ensuite elle fait la crèche c'est à
dire qu'elle ne fait pas qu'elle biotech
a livré ce soir donc elle change
elle vit des poubelles etc ça va durer
combien de temps sa belle à 170 heures à
faire d'accor dont de cette première
semaine et elle commence de 9h à 12h de
14h à 19h d'accord voilà maintenant elle
elle assume totalement elle a vécu elle
a fait de la prison elle a été en prison
sa peine a été incarcéré pendant sera
deux mois et demi elle a eu un mélange
aménagement de peine ou même d'autres
prisonniers bien sûr et maintenant elle
assume sa peine totalement et c'est vrai
qu'elle est elle est contente de le
faire hier je les trouvais très ému et
très sincère dans ce qu elle me
racontait parce qu'elle me disait elle à
été star très jeune nabil à elle n'a pas
eu une vie comme les autres
attention aux critiques ou pas mais là
pas une vie comme les autres
aujourd'hui elle m'a dit moi ça m'a
rappelé en fait la vraie vie et le fait
de vider les poubelles même si j'en
rigole sur snap même si je le montre ça
m'a fait quelque chose et ça m'a fait me
rappeler que ben oui mes parents ils ont
travaillé
j'en ai juste pas la question que j'ai
posée à d'autres maggie la question
c'est ce qu'elle soit touchée qu'elle le
fasse avec sérieux et pas de souci la
question choquait pas choqué c'est est
ce que ça vous choque
quel le film et que finalement elle ait
l'air de s'amuser avec tous en même
temps dell film ce que des filles je
crois vous êtes choqués vous oui oui je
suis choquée effectivement elle montre
toute sa vie et ses sons c'est son
métier donc elle peut montrer ce
qu'elles mangent le matin et ça ça
intéresse tout le monde apparemment
mais le côté juridique lorsqu elle purge
une peine elle devrait pas le montrer et
après la conclusion c'est quoi
effectivement peut-être qu'elle prend ça
au sérieux elle peut le prendre au
sérieux mais le soir et bien se faire
chercher par son copain en voiture et
qu'elle
la conclusion est ce que serait ce que
parce que elle a fait une bêtise et
parce qu'aujourd'hui elle fait des
travaux d'intérêt général son fiancé n'a
pas droit de venir lâche pas d'accord
mais là c'est quelqu'un sait quelque
chose
écoute de faire entrer une son téléphone
et où elle est là pour bosser donc déjà
elle a besoin de tenir son téléphone
d'une main parce que vider la poubelle
d'une main et le téléphone mais c'est ça
le message et les ailes à satory
temagami ces deux là par la mairie mais
tu peux comprendre magali qu en terme de
symbole l'a10 et des images en terme de
symbole s'est exécuté une peine à tous
décote exécute une paix n'est qu'à la
fin ton mec bien de chercher de tv
réalité avec une bagnole à 200000 euros
tu peux comprendre qu'à terme de sa
valse a pu choquer des gens jusqu'au
bout mais ça ne choque pas myriam année
ça vous choque pas moi ça me choque et
je trouve ça complètement honteux
pourtant j'ai rien contre nabila mais
franchement là elle a rendu le truc
complètement trivial fin on a
l'impression qu'elle est là en train de
filmer à façon snapshot c'est
complètement ridicule
et franchement ça elle est suivie par
des par des millions de jeunes
c'était vraiment pas un exemple qu'elle
donne elle fait quoi oui moi j'ai fait
des chutes et aux travaux d'autres
régions d'europe
d'accord avec en même temps je
m'améliore avec ça ou d'un point de vue
communication c'est très adroit alors
bien sûr elle ce film des communications
pour l appât pour ces trucs
c'est très adroit elle est suivie par
des millions de fans que tu que tu
connais bien voilà tout un public et
elle se montre en posture assez
dévalorisant pour elle c'est rare et
elle montre aussi qu'elle fait c'est
tout d'abord et général je finis je
faisais juste et donc d'un point en même
temps on voit qu'elle n'est pas
intouchable et qu'elles accomplissent de
la justice est la même pour tous alors
après qu'elles se filme sa part
apparaître un petit peu dérisoire y
compris merci intéressant que catherine
dès qu'il décrypte comme ça en tout cas
là son jugement lu que non c'est vrai
elle a le parti dont elle montre qu'elle
fait ces travaux qu'à la paf a sauté le
truc on veut en payant une amende ou ans
on est en balade où ils jugent non mais
les à-côtés te dire tu es condamné tu
fais même c'était la villa et elle
montre quand même assez jeune à qui la
regardent pas même que du coup oui mais
là la voix tremblotante meinau mais elle
le faire à lanières désinvolte web
super alors après deux minutes avant le
second c'est mieux seul guillaume
secondes tu devines qu'avant la variole
chose à filmer elle monte son mec tout
nue dans son bain
en fait elles n'ont on a fait ça bien
habile à je n'arrive pas à comprendre si
elle est intelligente ou totalement
stupide ce qui est sûr c'est qu'elle ne
comprend pas qu'il ya des choses qui
sont graves et d'autre et le conte ya
des jeunes qui la regarde et bien moi
j'en parlais à ce procès et qu'elle est
là où elle attend le résultat de mon
procès mais oui c'est ça y est les
débits alors je n'attends rien c'est pas
choquer mais ce que tu peux comprendre
aussi que nabila qu'il faut pas oublier
que non et pour les gens si elle fait ça
c'est parce qu'à l'origine elle a quand
même poignardé savola voilà tout ça ne
part pas d'une blague sans elle et elle
est comme tous les êtres humains
aujourd'hui qui font des erreurs elle
est jugée par des juges on n'est pas des
juges donc à des sujets parfois arrêter
comprendre d'accord on n'est pas la
justice
aujourd'hui elle peine elle être purge
sa peine comme tout le monde sans aucun
avantage
comme tout le monde non pas comme tout
le monde et six mois non pas comme tout
le monde tout le monde paie pas en
galère 56 euros par mois en bourse a
annulé mais maintenant si elle prend un
des gros montants par moi aussi c'est
qu'elle les a mérités c'est qu'elle sait
que ça plaît c'est qu'on l'a tout le
monde n'a pas sa vie c'est ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le dit pas un mot
c'est daniel moreau pas choquer alors je
vous avoue franchement j'avais pas vu la
ferrari à la fin ça me choque un petit
peu ça ce décalage mais je trouve c'est
nabil a d'abord elle à cette attitude là
tout le temps ça peut vous appeler pas
elle est là et puis elle et elle parle
qu'aux jeunes et c'est une star de télé
réalité là on est en plein dedans il ya
deux il ya du bien y'a pas bien et je
trouve que si un petit message une
petite subtilité c'est que les jeunes on
se rend compte que peut-être si on fait
une connerie on va se trouver avec lui
elle est là elle envoie ses six frères
yeux évident
c'est là justement elle m'a fonce on a
l'impression ne sait rien du tout
aujourd'hui vers l'avenir
moi j'entends tout ce que vous me dites
mais ce qu'on n'a pas le sentiment que
finalement si tu me regardes ton mec
bon bah derrière laissera derrière lui
mais tous les chefs de cuisine à elle
devrait payer plus la juge est alors
qu'elle n'a été fait des snapshots et
son choix de vie elle a toujours vécu
comme ça mais ça vous avez peut lui
reconnaître une chose et je pense que
vous êtes tous d'accord pour ceux qui la
connaissent ici c'est qu'elle ne se
prend pas pour ce qu'elle est pas et
elle se montre dans des dents des façons
qui peuvent effectivement là faut
arrêter m'ont ordonné de magali
j'entends et contrairement à ce que dit
perte d'un drone la jugent pas parce que
ça fait débat et moi même si dans le
débat et quand elle vient des pmp soir
c'est ce que j'utilise twitter orange
comme ça je le dis je suis nabila je
trouve que ce qu'elle montre peut être
parfois détestable et quand elle vient
tpm paix comme hier soir j'étais avec
elle je ris je rigole avec dans les
loges dans les loges sont une fille
formidable et ce qu'elle montre en
revanche sont que c'est plus compliqué
ça c'est vraiment que mon avis mais
j'entends mais moi je vais vous la
regardez aussi je la regarde elle fait
moi je trouve qu'elle mène super bien sa
barque et tout mais si maintenant vous
tombez sur une vidéo sur internet d'un
mec qui fait des travaux d'intérêt
général qui se filme comme ça qu'est ce
qu'on va écrire un commentaire
on va écrire bah écoute retrousse toi
les manches post santé les fans et va
travailler parce que c'est le but de la
journée c'est d'être à bd va falloir
réaliser des films et je pense qu'il a
raillé n'en écoute non monsieur n'est
pas avec elle la journée pour savoir ce
qu'elle fait aujourd'hui et dans ses
dents sont dans ces heures de travail
pas déjà quant à son iphone mais moi je
n'y suis pas mais vous n'y êtes pas non
plus on aurait dit c'est bon elle n'est
que très très bien en narration qu'on a
tout changé
après sébastien chabal et c'est vrai que
tous les gens qui sont des travaux
d'intérêt général ne filme pas regardé
par 1 tu les connais pas
on connaît pas excuse moi mais je
l'imaginé pas de bêtises on s'en rend
les gens s'en vantera renom les gens
s'en vont désormais réagi sur twitter
évidemment dit mis tout ce qu'ils en
pensent et très intéressant de savoir ce
que vous en pensez est ce que ça vous
choque ou pas ça ce sera vraiment
intéressant dans leur état de ce sondage
là après magali reconnaît que tu dis les
autres ce film pas bah oui eux mêmes sur
les causes et les gens une lambda
ce rôle lui téléphonerait vote de
minutes comme une tête qu'on sent
surtout par le sondage est peut-être que
magali pas raison si et que certains
sont trop durs aussi c'était aussi un
problème générationnel
bref y'a plein plein plein question
[Applaudissements]